supongamos que estás estudiando una
pequeña colina o formación rocosa como
la que tenemos aquí y de alguna manera
has podido calcular las dimensiones
sabes que esta línea a nivel del suelo
mide 60 metros este lado más inclinado
de esta roca o esta saliente como
quieras llamarlo mide 20 metros mientras
que este lado este lado menos inclinado
mide 50 metros de longitud
pudiste medir todo eso y ahora lo que
quieres hacer es aplicar sus
conocimientos de trigonometría para que
con esa información calcular cuál es la
inclinación de este lado cuál es la
elevación que tiene con respecto al
suelo
en pocas palabras queremos saber cuánto
mide este ángulo que vamos a llamar
theta te invito a que le pongas pausa el
vídeo y pienses por un momento cómo
resolverías el problema bien aquí
podemos recordar que si conocemos los
tres lados de un triángulo y queremos
calcular un ángulo podemos usar la ley
de cosenos vamos a escribir la ley de
cosenos antes de que lo intentemos
aplicar para resolver el problema que
tenemos en este triángulo la ley de seno
se establece qué
se cuadrada es igual a cuadrada más be
cuadrada menos 2 ave coseno de teta en
esta fórmula a b y c representan los
lados del triángulo donde se es el lado
opuesto al ángulo teta esto lo podemos
ver mejor en este triángulo si en este
triángulo este es el ángulo theta el
lado opuesto a theta que es este que
tenemos aquí es el lado c mientras que
es indistinto cuál es o cuáles d ya que
si te fijas bien juegan el mismo papel
en la ley de cosenos de hecho puedes
intercambiar las puedes decir que este
es el lado b y este es el agua realmente
esto no afecta a la fórmula apliquemos
entonces la ley de cosenos para
encontrar el ángulo theta que nos
interesa para esto identifiquemos cuáles
son los valores correspondientes en la
fórmula este es el lado ce el lado a o b
es indiferente cual tomamos digamos que
este es el lado a mientras que este de
aquí va a ser el lado b ya podemos
entonces aplicar la ley d
se nos hagámoslo por acá tenemos que se
al cuadrado que es 20 al cuadrado es
igual a al cuadrado que es 50 al
cuadrado más b al cuadrado más 60 al
cuadrado menos 2 veces menos 2 veces el
producto de a por de menos 2 veces el
producto de 50 por 60 y eso multiplicado
por el coche no de teta lo cual está
perfecto pues nos están dando todos los
valores excepto la incógnita que es el
ángulo teta
veamos cómo despejar teta aquí tenemos
20 al cuadrado que es 400 eso es igual a
50 al cuadrado que es 2500
+ 60 al cuadrado que son 3600
- dos veces 50 por 60 2 por 50 son 100
por 60 esto es 6 mil vamos a simplificar
esta expresión tenemos del lado
izquierdo 400 que es igual a 2500 más
3600 esto es 2 mil 3 mil 5000 6.100 deja
de ponerlo con otro color vamos a sumar
entonces 2.500 más 3600 que es 6.100
está bien 2000 3000 5500 más 600 mil 100
si seis mil 100 y eso tenemos que
restarle
que multiplica a coseno de teta y ahora
podemos restar 6.100 a ambos lados de la
ecuación restamos 6.100 al lado
izquierdo y al lado derecho pues
queremos despejar coseno beteta entonces
que nos queda del lado izquierdo 400
menos 6 mil 100 esto nos va a dar igual
a menos 5.700 veamos 5.700 más 400 es
6.100 si fuera 6 mil 100 menos 400 sería
5.700 pero como el negativo de 6.100 nos
queda menos 5.700 si muy bien estos
6.100 se cancelan y esto es igual a
menos 6 mil que multiplica a jose no
detecta ahora dividimos ambos lados
entre menos 6.000 dividimos ambos lados
entre menos 6.000 aquí tenemos que estos
menos 6.000 se cancelan de tal manera
que la ecuación ahora nos queda coseno
de teta es igual a
veamos aquí podemos dividir entre -100
el numerador y el denominador así es que
estos signos menos se hacen más y nos
quedaría coseno beteta es igual a 57
dividido entre 60 y todavía podemos
simplificar más esto a ver si dividimos
entre 3 57 entre 33 19 si esto sería
igual
jose no detecta es igual a 19 sobre 20
esta última simplificación quizá no era
necesaria pues vamos a sacar la
calculadora sin embargo un resultado
simplificado es mucho más elegante y
facilita las matemáticas y ahora podemos
tomar coseno inverso a ambos lados para
obtener que teta es igual a coseno
inverso o el ángulo cuyo coste no es 19
sobre 20 el ángulo cuyo coste no es 19
sobre 20 para obtener este valor sacamos
la calculadora
entonces vamos a calcular el coste no
inverso de 19 sobre 20 y 19 sobre 20 y
esto es igual esto es igual a 18.19 4 y
verificamos que nuestra calculadora esté
en grados si efectivamente nuestro valor
está bien merecemos un redoble de
tambores de tal manera que el valor del
ángulo theta el valor del ángulo theta
es aproximadamente 18 punto 2 grados si
lo aproximamos a décimas hemos obtenido
así una buena estimación de qué tan
inclinado está este lado de la colina